what's going on guys this is rob and
while we are covering invincible on
patreon i hit people up on patreon and
said hey do you guys care if we cover
this on the main channel
and there were a couple people who were
kind of like ah you know i kind of like
it being on patreon
but most people were like nah it'd be
kind of cool if you did that right
because they want to see what other
people's reactions are like so we're
gonna test this
i'm gonna throw up invincible volume two
right technically season one of the
invincible show
more or less ends with like issue 26 of
the comic book series
uh if you guys are are going out and
buying it and you guys are reading it
season one ends with issue 26 i mean
there's
maybe a couple other issues after that
or like some little tidbits from future
issues 27 28 different things like that
but we're just going to test this right
and i'm curious to see
how people are going to respond to this
if people are going to care or if
they're not going to care
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and uh i'm a little late
to the party here but it's been a super
busy day today uh but we are picking up
with
more of invincible right now this part
that we pick up with here is
a part that already aired with regards
to the tv show um but we basically end
up kind of joining with mark when he
gets a call from his dad right when
nolan calls him up and says hey man you
know i gotta go do a thing
with uh the guardians of the globe but
there's gonna be an alien showing up
here he's a pretty bad guy
make sure you deal with him and so mark
ultimately ends up taking off in his
space now the funny thing is this is the
first time we learn
that nolan can actually hold his breath
for like two weeks mark can hold his
breath like an hour or something along
those lines
once uh mark gets to space then suddenly
he's met by the arrival of alan the
alien now here's a cool thing alan the
alien is probably one of the most
important characters of invincible uh
but initially you don't get that instead
he's just kind of here
and there's a bit of a fight that breaks
out between the two of them now alan
also uses telepathy which is how he and
mark were able to communicate with each
other and for the most part allen
demonstrates a pretty good amount of
proficiency in fighting right in
hand-to-hand combat
certainly more so than mark because
mark's still pretty much brand new to
the whole thing but ultimately mark
takes him into the moon right just like
crashes them into the moon and then they
kind of start talking things out
and that's when allen reveals that he's
part of a group called the coalition of
planets right and the whole idea behind
this
is basically when these individuals are
sent off into space for the purpose of
like
safeguarding planets now the coalition
sends what is basically somebody like
allen to kind of test them to see how
capable they are
in terms of protecting various worlds so
he's what's called a champion evaluation
officer
uh now the funny thing about this is
that he is actually at the wrong planet
that that in essence uh he basically
says that he's here to visit a planet
called urath and in reality he's
actually at earth now the crazy thing is
he's kind of like okay
definitely the wrong world and then he
kind of go they kind of go through like
these 50-year rotations more or less and
that he's up for like a new rotation or
a
really an evaluation in like 20 years
and he's been basically coming to the
wrong world
for the last 15 years right so it's kind
of nuts he's basically been doing
terrible at his job and
ultimately kind of takes off right once
he realizes that he's basically in the
wrong place and he and mark more or less
i wouldn't say become
friends but they're they have kind of a
familiar relationship right it's kind of
like okay cool you're a cool guy well
you're a cool guy too awesome you know
let's kind of call it a day from there
when mark gets back he kind of tells his
dad about you know everything that had
gone on
and the fact that this guy allen alien
had been showing up to the wrong planet
for the last 15 years and initially
nolan kind of takes it in a funny way
and then he's like okay well i'm pretty
impressed you were able to handle it
that way you know that kind of a thing
and so you know of course mark has
homework and stuff to take care of but
from there things actually get
particularly interesting here and the
reason why
is because william of course as most of
you guys know a friend of mark is coming
to see mark the next day because they're
actually going to uh to upstate
university to kind of check out you know
the college campus right
where he's going to be going to school
at and so the funny thing is that while
they're doing that
basically nolan and and his wife are
kind of like all right i mean you know
time to touch naughty bits right
it's just you know kind of you know it's
time to do the damn thing because the
kid's gone while that's going on
robot basically calls together the
remainder or really the the other
members
of team team and kind of says look i've
been you know kind of moved up to the
the guardians of the globe right i've
been like you know promoted to their
ranks but i'm also disbanding this team
because
i cannot efficiently be a part of both
right and so it's really kind of a last
goodbye to robot where they're kind of
like cool you know go on ahead and do
your thing and sort of call it a day and
then you also have a guy by the name of
sanford now sanford is a guy who had
powers at one point in time
and by whatever manner and whatever
means which we won't reveal here
basically lost them and the result was
that he was essentially kicked off the
guardian's team right because he
didn't have any powers they didn't
really have any use for him and they're
basically he's basically waiting on like
a replacement suit right from the tailor
a guy who can kind of give him a new
suit that'll essentially give him his
powers back or at least some measure of
powers and he can regain his rightful
place on the guardians right so that's
where it's kind of given to us
that robot is essentially taking the
place of sanford on the team it's more
or less what's happening and it's going
to be two days until it happens which is
really more than just sanford seems to
be able to wait now at this point he
seems to be of seems to have been out of
the team for a little while so what's
two days right in comparison to all that
and so kind of jumping out with mark and
william william kind of pisses a few
people off
just because of the fact that you know
because his name's william bill is a
shorthand name for that and a few people
are like hey man like do you prefer bill
and that's one of those social social
etiquette things where it's a person
saying like can i call you bill but not
really saying that and it's like it's
actually william right and it just seems
to kind of rub people the wrong way i
don't know why this is why i don't
really care about social norms right
they're really more annoying than
anything else it's not that i don't
understand them it's just that i find
social norms to be a nuisance
so more often than not i usually just
ignore them and just kind of do my own
thing
it does kind of rub people the wrong way
but at the end of the day i don't really
care
uh you know they'll be fine they'll get
over it and it's one of the kind of
discussions that goes on and even
william kind of puts that idea forward
like man
you know here's the thing he's like you
know it's kind of irritating he's like
you know if i tell them
sure you can call me bill then they
don't call me by the name that i prefer
but if i say i prefer william then they
see me as kind of like rude or snooty
because i'm william instead of bill you
know so he's like it's lou's lose and
i'm like you know what william who cares
man it doesn't really matter all that
much
and they kind of run into this issue a
couple of different times but then
something amazing happens right it's one
of the funniest things ever so you
basically end up having this
really like a villain more or less that
seemingly shows up out of nowhere and
then goes to attack mark while he's with
william right and the reality is he's
actually heading in a direction
it's just everybody else there is more
or less collateral damage but mark's
like oh my god oh
man like what was that you know he's
like william get out of the way and then
mark takes off changes into his costume
come
comes back and then basically destroys
the robot and then just kind of like
disappears and returns his mark and he's
like william man
are you okay you know i can't believe
that happened and william's like dude
why didn't you tell me you had super
powers
right off the bat william figures out
that mark is invincible right and
honestly it kind of makes sense and i
love that robert kirkman did this
because only an idiot would fall for
like the superman thing you know where
like somebody's attacking the city
and and clark's like oh man i forgot
something in the office you know and
then he goes and you know changes into a
superman costumer like takes off a shirt
and a superman underneath and then he
defeats the villain then he comes back
and
nobody's any the wiser like man clark
you missed the whole thing you know it's
things like that that never made any
sense to me it's one of the things we
always kind of poke at and it's kind of
funny right when you're when you're
reading it but uh but nonetheless you
know it's a it's a little weird there
of course we also get a little bit of a
visit between mark and nolan showing up
to meet the tailor only for the taylor
to basically reveal that he had been in
the process of developing a suit
for sanford that would basically give
him his powers back but the suit has
essentially been stolen now
the implication as it's given here by
the tailor is that it looks like a
sanford he doesn't say that it is
he's just kind of like uh man it's a
little weird right like you know this
guy was supposed to get his powers back
in a couple days he indicated he
couldn't wait
suddenly the suit goes missing right
like he's the only person that really
knew that i was working on a suit form
that kind of a thing and so that's
that's you know
it kind of points and kind of really
points to the idea that that he was the
reason why it happened right
the stanford was the reason why this
this all kind of went down and so from
there what we end up doing here
is basically picking you up with with
something pretty interesting but
it's really something that you've
already seen before you do get kind of
like the the you know who are the
guardians of the globe the realities the
guardians of the globe are basically the
justice league so there's really not
anything
here of any significance that you didn't
probably catch in the tv show but
basically the guardians have all kind of
been called together and then they're
all basically killed by nolan now
something that i do want to point out
here
is the quickness in which they died here
was much faster than it was in the show
in the show the guardians put up a fight
and the comic it happened like within
the span of seconds right and that was
really designed
i imagine by kirkman to really show us
just how powerful nolan is
and you know in relation to everybody
else that like none of them really have
a chance on him he's just that damn
powerful but it's also kind of this
revelation
that nolan's a bad guy right like nolan
killed the entire guardians of the globe
and so it's kind of okay like now here's
a crazy thing
as nuts as this revelation is it only
gets crazier right like the story of
nolan only gets
more and more insane but it's one of
these things where like as soon as this
dropped i remember reading this as soon
as this dropped
it was mind-blowing it was like holy cow
now of course
following that nolan of course doesn't
tell anybody he killed the guardians of
the globe and he kind of lets everybody
go on the operation that like man
the guardians have been taken out by
somebody and it's kind of nuts he sort
of plays into it and he's like you know
i'm still kind of in shock you know by
by knowing that happened that's
absolutely bonkers you know and again
it's a little bit of detective work
going on
trying to figure out how the guardians
die but one of the things that i want
you guys to notice here
is nobody suspects nolan right and
that's something that we're going to
find later on but you end up picking up
with mark when he gets back home
and finds eve in his bedroom and i mean
she's crying right so obviously the
circumstances could be much much
better and that's when you basically end
up finding out that rex had cheated on
eve
right now i'm gonna be honest with you
guys rex is a little bit of an idiot for
cheating on eve but at the same time
he's kind of not
because kate can duplicate herself so
like you could have a threesome like any
time you want and it's kind of like
i mean okay rex i kind of understand
where you're coming from you know what i
mean like i mean you don't sanction it
like you're not like oh yeah good job
rex you cheated on your girl you don't
really sanction it the real question you
have to ask here is that if kate
duplicates herself and then she gets
into a threesome with somebody else is
it considered incest that's
that's a real question you have to ask
right i mean this really took a dark
turn
that's why these videos don't go on the
regular youtube channel guys but
nonetheless right as soon as
as mark's mom shows up in the bedroom
and realizes he's there you know he's
like is basically laying her head
in mark's lap so like from behind it
looks like the worst case scenario
right it looks it looks like it looks
like mark's getting some dome and so
she calls him downstairs and really kind
of starts reading the riot act and it's
like look you don't understand right
like we're not banging like we're not
we're not touching naughty boots but at
the end of the day
like you know it's just one of these
things where i'm kind of helping her get
through a situation right that kind of a
thing now of course
nolan also reveals the guardians of the
globe are dead which is kind of a crazy
thing and that's what's also sort of
nuts
is that it's really eve in a lot of ways
kind of figuring out that like
mark is the son of of omni man right
which is a pretty big deal right that's
that's a that's a huge thing to go down
but ultimately you kind of have mark
and nolan who are going to the funeral
for the guardians and again like one of
the things that you notice here you
actually don't see it in the tv show
you've got savage dragon
this is one of those few instances when
characters from image comics will cross
over with each other doesn't happen very
often but you do get savage dragon which
is kind of cool but again this is one of
those instances where like nolan gets up
there and starts making a speech and
then you have the mahler twins who show
up now the mauler twins again are like
these evil geniuses
one of them's a clone the other is the
original and and for the most part
they're always usually up to some
nefarious purposes but it's one of these
things where they kind of seem to show
up here for like literally
offering their genuine respect to a
great team right to a powerful team
and so ultimately no one again no one
here suspects nolan like
no one here looks at nolan it's like
dude i bet nolan did it and i bet nolan
was the guy who killed the guardians of
the globe nobody says that right because
nolan is is considered such a prodigious
character
the sort of ambiance he puts off right
the kind of personality he puts off is
beyond reproach he's so respected nobody
thinks it would be him right so it's
like the perfect guys
and so ultimately like the whole funeral
is like literally interrupted like
somebody somebody literally hits a
funeral
right it's it's nuts like they hit a
funeral and it turns out to be like the
butler to sanford
right that's the crazy thing is like the
butler kind of went nuts and was pissed
off because of what happened to sanford
right and so when that when that whole
thing goes down like literally everybody
moves right everybody starts getting
into getting into action uh going after
the butler which for the most part
they're able to kind of take this guy
out right like omniman just takes him
out with a swiftness and that's
essentially it and then from there it's
kind of like okay like the whole crowd
kind of disperses
and that's that's it right there's not a
whole lot going on there and so from
there you get a couple things that
happen one of them is pretty cool right
like william shows up to mark's house
and it's like hey man look um
so i know you have powers and i know
this seems kind of weird but like can
you fly me into the sky
and so mark flies his friend around for
a little while which is pretty awesome
and then the kind of conclusion here by
the kind of finale is again like you end
up having one of these guys who is
basically
you know kind of converted into a bomb
by david hiles right you guys remember
him from the last story that we did
where he was essentially a villain right
he was a guy who was
turning kids into bombs and then
detonating him one of these kids of
course survived the whole experience but
the bomb stays attached to him right i
mean it's more or less neutralized but
like he has to have those components as
part of his body
in order to survive and he literally
starts to take like he just unzips his
pants and just pisses on the guy's grave
but then you have a couple kids who also
show up here
to basically you know dig up or or to
really kind of
really dig up the graves of these guys
and part of this is is just
nonsense right like supposedly if you
drink from the immortal skull you'll
live forever right immortal being one of
the members of the guardians of the
globe it's kind of nuts like you know
they read about it on the internet it's
a complete dick move right so like go to
go to the grave of superheroes and like
dig their graves up but as they kind of
get further down and essay ultimately
hits where the graves are
suddenly they're met with the arrival of
the mauler twins so again these guys are
definitely up to no good what it is that
they're up to well we'll have to wait
and find out for the next video but that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for being
patrons i love you guys to death
and i will catch you all later peace